George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Kit Kats in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, our Kit Kats come in four sizes,
big little pouch bite,
minis,
and bar,
and classy one, Sublime.
So, one thing to note
here regarding mini sizes,
the regular Kit Kat is 11.6 grams,
but the flavored minis, such as matcha,
are said to be slightly
smaller, 11.3 grams.
So I'm going to weigh them now to confirm.
So, let's weigh a
regular-flavor Kit Kat first.
It weighs 11 grams.
But it doesn't show the decimal points,
it says just 11 grams.
Let's weigh matcha flavor.
12.
It's actually heavier than regular flavor.
Interesting.
Japanese Kit Kats have become
popular all around the world,
and the US, of course, is no exception.
I just want to mention at the top here,
we're going to be talking about Kit Kats
that are native to our countries.
I know you can get them online.
I think Walmart.com has some of them.
Fantastic. They're imported.
We know. Thank you.
In the US, our Kit Kats
come in nine sizes.
Starting from the smallest,
we have a Kit Kat minis unwrapped,
then the thins,
miniatures,
snack size,
standard four finger,
the Big Kat.
From there, we move up
to king size, which is,
a piece accidentally broke off
and then I accidentally ate it.
The Big Kat king size.
So it looks like it's just two Big Kats.
And the biggest size, the XL.
A bag of Kit Kat bites
should have 11 bites.
Let's count in Japanese.
Ichi, ni, san, shi, go,
roku, shichi, hachi, ku, juu,
juuichi.
11 bites.
And according to the bag,
the combined weight should be 50 grams.
So let's weigh all 11 bites.
Ooh!
It weighs 52 grams.
Good deal.
All of our US sizes come
in a variety of units,
depending on your Kit Kat needs.
So many varieties.
Here's a few worth mentioning.
The minis. The biggest
bag of minis unwrapped
you can get is 419 grams.
As the title implies,
these things are unwrapped little bites.
It's sold like it's for
sharing, but get real.
Whoever sticks their hand in
here first, it's their bag.
For the miniatures, according to Amazon,
you can get up to 4-pound bags,
aka 1,814.37 grams.
And what it looks like, they just sent me
a bag that's loosely 4
pounds of Kit Kat minis.
All the bars have their various packs.
None of them seem unusual.
I will, however, mention that
the biggest single purchase
of a Kit Kat item you can get
is the king-size 24-pack.
The total here is 2,040 grams,
about 4.5 pounds of Kit Kat.
Here's all the Kit Kats
exclusive to the US.
And here is all the Kit
Kats native to Japan.
Kit Kat in Japan is made by Nestlé
and is one of the best-selling
candies in the country.
One of the reasons for its popularity
is that Kit Kat has a
good-luck charm in Japan
because the name Kit Kat
in Japanese is Kitto Katto.
And Kitto Katto sounds like "kitto katsu,"
which means "you will surely win."
So the Kit Kat brand became
associated with good luck.
And these Kit Kats are
often given to students
before their exams.
For the past 20 years,
Kit Kat has introduced more
than 350 unique flavors.
Wow!
Some of them are
discontinued, unfortunately,
and some of them are regional,
so we couldn't get them by
the filming of this episode.
Gomen ne!
So here are a few standard
Kit Kat flavors in Japan.
Coffee break.
But it doesn't taste like coffee,
but goes well with coffee.
So I brought my coffee with me today,
so let's see how it goes.
Itadakimasu.
It's actually pretty good,
much better than expected.
So, next we have
melon.
Mm!
It's so melon.
It has way too strong melon flavor.
Next, we have chocolate orange.
Overall, not bad.
Next, graham cracker.
This is fantastic.
Next, I'm gonna go
cheesecake.
This is marvelous.
If you're a cheesecake person like me,
you will definitely like this.
Next, strawberry cheesecake.
You get some decent strawberry flavor
and cheesecake flavor at the
same time, which is amazing.
Next, apple cinnamon.
I'm not a big fan of this.
There is a lot of cinnamon in it,
which makes this horrible.
Pistachio.
Look at this cute squirrel!
Kawaii ne!
Kawaii!
It's not great, but not horrible either.
Next, pudding.
Mm!
Mm, it's disgusting.
It's way too sweet.
Let's go next one.
We have strawberry milk.
Ah!
Holy crap.
This is nasty.
This is the worst one.
So, this is the last one.
I've got cookies and cream.
This is the best thing I
have ever had in my mouth.
Sorry to interrupt.
But believe it or not,
the US does have a few exclusive flavors
you can't get in Japan.
First up,
pumpkin pie.
Yo!
This tastes exactly like pumpkin pie.
Yeah, they hit it out of
the park with that one, wow.
Key lime pie.
This one's so good.
It tastes just like key lime pie.
These are both fantastic.
Fruity cereal.
What cereal is this?
Is that Froot Loops?
Tastes exactly like Froot Loops.
Gingerbread.
Raspberry creme.
I love this one.
Yo, Joe,
Yuelei.
All right, try it, let's go.
What do you guys think?
Yeah, yeah, Starbursts, good call.
Witch's brew?
"Crispy wafers and
marshmallow flavored cream."
These are great.
Yeah, it has, like, a
frosting flavor to it.
Then we got glow in the dark.
Wait, what's supposed to glow in the dark?
The packaging or the ... ?
That's not fun!
I thought this was going
to glow in the dark!
The packaging?
Let's see it, let's give it a shot.
Nothing's glowing.
All right. Lights back on.
It's a regular Kit Kat.
This is regular. How
disappointing is that?
Thumbs down.
Birthday cake.
Close to a frosting and sprinkles flavor.
Man, these are all really good.
Also in the US, you can
get a lemon crisp flavor.
Sold out everywhere.
It was like a Supreme drop.
The second those hit the
shelves, they were are gone.
Also Kit Kat in the US
has this line called Duos.
As you can see, three different flavors,
two flavors in one.
We got mint and dark chocolate.
Mocha and chocolate.
Eh, I'm already,
I'm not predicting this is
going to be anything special.
It's just OK.
Strawberry and dark chocolate.
Is the way I'm eating these annoying?
I mean, it's not terrible, but.
Maybe strawberry and chocolate
would've been too sweet,
but with the dark chocolate,
I'm just not into it.
So these were fun, right? These were fun?
No?
All right, back to Japan.
Kit Kat has a collection of flavors
inspired by the many regions
and prefectures of Japan.
So I'm going to start
with this, Mount Fuji,
the highest mountain in Japan.
It's 3,776 meters high.
And the flavor is
strawberry-cheesecake flavor.
How can I open this?
Here we go.
It looks great.
It's pretty good.
But it tastes exactly the same
as that one that I tasted 10 minutes ago.
All right, next one is this Shinshu apple.
Shinshu is kind of very old way
to call Nagano Prefecture.
And Nagano Prefecture is
located in the center of Japan
and is famous for delicious apples.
And, finally, they turn into Kit Kat.
Ooh.
This is the nicest
chocolate I've ever had.
Next, we have Amaou strawberry.
So it's basically from Kyushu.
Kyushu is Japan's third-largest island
and is located southwest of Japan.
And Amaou is the best brand
of strawberries in Japan.
Marvelous, again.
Next, I'm going to go with this one.
Ito Kyuemon Uji matcha
and Ito Kyuemon Uji hojicha.
Uji matcha and Uji hojicha
are named after Uji city,
where they're grown.
And the difference between
matcha and hojicha is
matcha is matcha, right?
Matcha is a green tea.
But hojicha is a roasted green tea.
Let's go with Uji matcha first.
Whoo!
Matcha is always perfect.
How about hojicha?
It's as beautiful as my heart.
Let's move on to the next one.
We have beni imo.
Beni imo, which is purple sweet potato.
It's from Okinawa.
So, Okinawa is Japan's
southernmost prefecture
and is famous for beni imo.
Okinawa is my favorite place in Japan.
I love this.
It has just right sweetness.
We've got azuki sandwich
flavor from Nagoya.
So, Nagoya is located in
between Tokyo and Osaka
and is famous for its azuki sandwich.
Azuki is sweet red bean paste.
So sweet red bean paste sandwich.
Oh.
It's not my taste at all.
Momiji manju flavor.
It's from Hiroshima.
So, Hiroshima is located
in the southwest of Japan
and is famous for its momiji manju,
which is kind of maple-leaf-shaped cake
filled with sweet bean paste.
It tastes exactly the same as this one.
Sweet red bean paste.
Japanese people love sweet red bean paste.
Hokkaido azuki and strawberry flavor.
Hokkaido is the largest
and northernmost prefecture in Japan
and is famous for its azuki.
Much better than the other azuki flavors.
Why wasabi?
And it's from Shizuoka,
and Shizuoka is located
along the Pacific coast
and is the top wasabi-producing
region in Japan.
Believe it or not, it's
actually pretty good.
Let's go! This one!
Strawberry cheesecake flavor again.
It's from Yokohama.
Yokohama is located next to Tokyo,
but Yokohama is not famous
for strawberry cheesecake.
I don't know why they chose
strawberry-cheesecake flavor for this.
It tastes exactly the same.
Same!
Next we have Tokyo banana.
So, Tokyo banana is a banana-shaped
sponge cake with cream filling,
and it is very popular souvenir of Tokyo.
And they turn into Kit Kats.
Ta-da! Ooh!
It's gross.
When you come to Tokyo, you
should try Tokyo bananas,
but you should not try
Tokyo banana Kit Kats.
Rum raisin.
It's from Tokyo.
Tokyo is not famous for rum raisin.
But it says, "Rum raisin's gorgeousness
and fanciness matches the image of Tokyo."
There is a shot of rum.
I don't like it!
It contains a lot of alcohol.
Ooh.
Nande?
Last one!
Sake flavor,
which is a Japanese traditional
alcohol made from rice.
This is a really interesting one.
Oh.
Personally, I like it.
And this is an acquired taste.
So, when it comes to sake flavor,
we were supposed to have
yogurt sake, yuzu sake,
limited-edition Japan sake umeshu,
but these were not available
at the time of filming this.
And we have Kit Kat desserts.
We have Kit Kat Colliders,
which I could not find
at the filming of this,
but it looks to be almost
like vanilla-flavored cups
with Kit Kat chunks broken up in it.
Oh, man, I ate too many Kit Kats.
And then we have these.
These Kit Kat ice cream cones.
Eh.
I hit a wall real hard.
I hit a giant Kit Kat XL wall,
and I officially do not
want to do this anymore.
Better, but not by much more.
Yeah, so that's it for the US.
Sorry we have so few flavors.
Japan has a Kit Kat called Otona no Amasa,
which translates to
"sweetness for adults."
Ow! R-rated!
Don't let your kids watch this part!
All right, so it's a
line of Kit Kat flavors
that are a little more bitter
and less sweet than regular Kit Kats.
So, here we have Otona
no Amasa strawberry,
white,
and dark matcha
and dark chocolate.
All right, so let's give it a try.
First.
This is just straight-up dark chocolate,
as you can imagine.
Strawberry.
Ooh, it's actually tart.
This is good.
All right, so let's
move on to the next one.
We've got dark matcha.
Mm.
This is so deep.
Much deeper than the other matcha flavors.
So, last one, we've got Otona
no Amasa white chocolate.
This is the best one
among these Otona no Amasa chocolates.
Just right sweetness.
All right, so let's do matcha taste test.
In Japan, matcha-flavored
Kit Kats are so popular.
Over the years, we've
introduced 13 different,
different, different,
different matcha flavors.
But currently, we were only
able to get these three.
So let's see how different they are.
First, dark matcha.
Deep matcha.
But it's also deep.
Ito Kyuemon Uji matcha.
So freaking hard to tell the difference.
But I'd say this one is
the most delicious one.
Kyoto.
You can get it in Kyoto or order online.
So, here we have classy
chocolates called Sublime.
So we have white Sublime
and raw milk Sublime
and a volcanic green Sublime
and orange volcanic Sublime,
yellow,
ruby Sublime.
All right, so let's try some out.
I'm getting sick of the sweetness.
Itadakimasu.
It doesn't taste anything!
I was thinking that it'd
taste like strawberry
or raspberry or something, but.
Did I get COVID?
COVID-19?
OK, let's keep going.
All right, so I'm going
to go yellow volcanic.
Volcano! Pew!
Ooh!
This is the bitterest.
I've got orange.
Bitter.
Now I'm so scared.
Green Sublime.
It tastes exactly same
as these two. So bitter.
Next we have milk Sublime.
It tastes exactly the
same as regular flavor.
I prefer this one.
Last one, I've got white Sublime.
Compared to the Otona no
Amasa white chocolate,
it's much better.
I'm done.
Hey, guys, it's Harry.
I can't let you do a Kit
Kat episode without me,
because Kit Kats were actually
invented in the UK in 1935.
They would eventually
be distributed by Nestlé
across the UK, the EU, and Japan.
But in the US, Kit Kats are made
and distributed by Hershey's.
If you watched our Snickers episode,
you'll know that there are
some major taste differences
between the chocolate
in the UK and the US.
Mostly that the UK's is way better.
I'm going to do a three-way taste test
between UK, US, and
also a Japanese Kit Kat
to see if there's any major
differences between the three.
And, Harry, thank you for sending me this
with your cute handwriting.
Thank you, Harry! Arigato.
Let's try UK Kit Kat first.
The UK one is obviously
the one I'm used to.
The chocolate is very smooth,
not overwhelmingly sweet,
and just very tasty.
The UK is already a lot richer.
OK, OK.
Can I try US Kit Kat?
I also couldn't find
just a standard American Kit Kat anywhere.
I guess we didn't bother
importing the regular one.
The closest thing I could find
was this Kit Kat Duos
mocha and chocolate one.
Something doesn't taste
quite right about that.
Yep.
UK, US,
they suck.
They both have too much sugar.
Joe, Harry, try Japan's Kit Kat.
Mm.
Much smoother. Creamier.
In terms of picking a favorite,
I think the US one gets
discounted immediately.
Then, between the UK and the Japan one,
it's kind of a different
style of Kit Kat, I guess.
I would say Japan and UK
are pretty neck and neck.
They seem very similar.
Japan's Kit Kat is the best in the world.
Ugh, I've eaten too much candy.
Ugh!
Perhaps we can pinpoint
the taste difference
to the ingredients.
In the US, a Kit Kat is made up of
sugar, wheat flour --
[beep]
Our Kit Kats have the following.
Looking over the ingredients,
I noticed our Kit Kats have
cocoa butter and chocolate,
although it does not specify
what that chocolate is made up of.
Do we assume it is the same
as the Hershey's chocolate bar?
I don't know.
Whereas the Japan Kit Kat has cocoa mass,
cocoa butter, and cocoa powder.
Now, if we're to believe
that Nestlé in Japan
holds their chocolate
to the same standards
they do in the UK, it would mean
that it would have a higher
fat and cocoa content.
According to the UK rules,
"a product must contain no
less than 25% cocoa solids
to be considered 'milk chocolate.'"
The US definitely does
not go by this rule.
Our Kit Kat is made up of palm oil,
where theirs is vegetable
oil. Same in the UK.
It is cheaper, but it's also
worse on the environment,
adding to deforestation,
increasing greenhouse [gas] emissions,
and water pollution.
So it is bad on the
environment and tastes worse.
Fantastic.
But good news for all you vegans,
Nestlé has created a vegan Kit Kat,
with substituted milk with
a rice-based alternative,
but availability is currently limited,
so they are not available
in the US or Japan.
This is a US Kit Kat miniature,
and it is 8.5 grams.
It's the closest size
we had to Japan's mini.
This is 42 calories,
2.2 grams of fat,
6 milligrams of sodium,
5.8 grams of carbs,
4 of those are sugar,
and 1 gram of protein.
In Japan, the mini is
the most popular size.
It's 62 calories
and 3.5 grams of fat,
3.5 to 11.4 milligrams of sodium,
8.99 to 19.4 grams of total carbs,
and 0.9 grams of protein.
The most common Kit Kat size in the US
is the four-finger bar.
210 calories,
11 grams of fat,
7 of those are saturated,
20 milligrams of sodium,
28 grams of carbs,
23 of those are sugar,
and 2 grams of protein.
The closest size we have to that in Japan
is the Kit Kat bar.
It contains 224 calories.
The most caloried Kit Kat in the US we got
is the Kit Kat XL.
Now, I unwrapped it here so you could see
just how big it is.
It contains 640 calories.
The most calories you will
get in a Kit Kat in Japan
is the big little pouch bite.
This bag is 275 calories.
George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here's everything you can find on the menu
at the Burger King in
Japan but not in the US.
Here's everything you can
find at a US Burger King
you cannot get in Japan.
All right, so let's start
with exclusive burgers.
So, here we have teriyaki lettuce burger
and teriyaki Whopper.
Ooh!
Huge.
Next we have avocado salad burger
and avocado Whopper.
Aah, a little cute baby.
Look at this.
And Whopper.
It's totally different.
This one is so huge.
And avocados, tomato,
no tomatoes.
I don't know why.
Next we have quattro cheese Whopper.
Oh, big boy.
We've got smoky barbecue Whopper
and smoky barbecue Whopper junior.
And here is spicy Whopper.
Ooh!
It's hot sauce.
Next, we have tartar chicken burger.
Ooh, it's got
a lot of tartar sauce,
chicken, crispy.
Burger King in Japan just
released a brand-new burger
called Guilty Burger.
It's basically butter burger.
Why?
What have you done?
Let's check out this Guilty
butter beef burger first.
The bun is different.
Itadakimasu!
Just a little bit of butter flavor,
but I don't feel as guilty as it claims.
This one is Guilty butter
croquette sandwich.
Ooh.
Guilty!
And here is Guilty butter chicken burger.
First one is something
that BK has exclu --
oh, my God.
This is called the Texas Whopper.
Look at the size of this f---ing thing.
Two patties, cheese,
bacon, bunch of veggies.
Wait for it!
The triple Whopper.
Look at the size of this thing.
The weight of it has completely
flattened the bottom bun.
And there's nothing between
the patties of meat!
What the hell are you
guys doing over there?
Next.
Oh, the Bacon King.
Oh, my God.
Looks to be pretty bacon centric.
Looks like a double Whopper with cheese,
bacon, mayo, ketchup, mustard.
They didn't mess with
the veggies. Thank you.
You're not fooling anyone
getting lettuce and onion on that one.
The rodeo burger is a
little guy with onion rings.
The rodeo burger. Yeehaw.
On to the chicken.
I'll just put this over here.
Japan does not have
what we call the original
chicken sandwich.
And I don't know why Burger King,
maybe just to set itself apart,
the chicken sandwich is
this, like, sub shape.
It's like I'm holding the phone.
This is great.
Chicken junior, spicy chicken junior.
Let's go spicy.
Barely registers in the spice meter.
Wait!
Yeah.
BKs in the US have something
called the Ch'King sandwich.
You can get the sandwich
regular or deluxe.
You can also get the sandwich
flavor regular or spicy.
So here is the regular regular.
And as you can see,
just comes with sauce and
pickles and the chicken.
You can get it deluxe and spicy,
so we went with deluxe,
comes with all these veggies
that you brush off right
when you start eating it,
and it has got a spicy kind
of hue to the chicken there.
Here's our side menu.
Let's start with this one.
We've got hot dog.
It's got such a big sausage.
This one is chili beans hot dog.
And next we have this little guy,
snack chicken.
And last we have this one,
chili cheese fries.
And if you want some veggies,
you can order Caesar salad.
But my bad, I forgot to order.
Also exclusives to the US
are these, chicken fries.
As you can tell, they look like fries,
but they're pieces of chicken.
Not bad.
You can get Mott's applesauce.
Jalapeño cheddar bites.
I've never heard of these.
And now I know why.
Burger King in the US has
two iced-coffee flavors,
mocha and vanilla.
Assuming that's the mocha.
Tastes exactly like chocolate milk.
Blech! No.
Oh, the aftertaste is horrible.
What the hell?
That's ridiculous how bad that is.
And the vanilla.
That is so sweet.
I'm gonna keep this one.
So, here is our dessert menus.
Here we have coffee float.
A little bit melting, sorry.
And we have melon soda float.
Coke float and Coke Zero float.
And here we've got premium
sundae chocolate and coffee.
And here is our chocolate sundae
and strawberry sundae.
And my favorite is this apple pie.
Desserts.
Here in the US you can get
yourself a Hershey's sundae pie.
Ugh.
This one might have got a
little roughed up in transit.
And in the US Burger King, you
can also get various shakes.
Here we have Oreo shake,
a chocolate Oreo shake,
a chocolate shake, and a vanilla shake.
All right.
God, that's so good.
The straight-up chocolate.
Oh, man, this is trouble.
Mm!
Wow, Burger King's shakes are really good.
I'm assuming this is just
the straight Oreo one.
Oh, my God, this is fantastic.
Are we all curious what a
chocolate Oreo shake tastes like?
Wonder no more.
Good. This one's the best.
Also at a US Burger King, you
can get a soft-serve cone.
I didn't get it,
only because we have no
refrigeration unit here
and it would just be a cone
with a puddle of ice cream. So.
Victoria, please turn me
into a giant soft-serve cone.
So, here are our drinks.
Let's start with this one.
This one is ginger ale;
and Fanta melon;
oolong tea,
which is Chinese tea;
and orange juice.
And this one is Earl Grey iced tea.
Next we have Darjeeling tea.
And here is Calpis,
which, you guys call it
Calpico in your country.
But in Japan we say "ka-ru pi-su."
I know it sounds like
"cow piss" in English,
but if you say Calpico to Japanese people,
they will never understand
what you're talking about.
So in Japan, once again,
we say "ka-ru pi-su."
Repeat after me. "Ka-ru pi-su."
Very good!
First things you can get,
you can get a little orange juice guy,
and you can also get
Capri Sun apple juice.
Shout-out to the pouch.
Burger King in the US has
Coke products as well,
but we have something called
a Coke Freestyle machine.
If you haven't seen it,
it's this big machine
that has a bunch of
Coca-Cola-related beverages.
You can mix and match them.
Anyway, we can get Hi-C fruit punch,
Hi-C pink lemonade, Fanta
orange, Mello Yello,
Powerade Zero, Dr Pepper,
Barq's, diet Barq's.
You can also get yourself a fat-free milk.
There it is.
Sweetened or unsweetened tea.
I think I got the sweetened.
I don't want any tea. Tea sucks.
We also have something
called frozen Cokes.
That is this right here.
As you can see, it's
been sitting for a while,
it's starting to separate.
But we have frozen Coke,
we also have a frozen Fanta wild cherry,
a frozen Fanta blue raspberry,
and a frozen strawberry lemonade.
Mm.
Oh, yeah.
Japan has a few exclusives
that are similar
but different to that in the US.
So, for example, this is
our plant-based Whopper.
This burger is made from 100% soybeans.
Itadakimasu!
It's actually delicious.
I like it.
Mm.
When it comes to
vegetarianism and veganism,
they are not that popular in Japan.
But gradually, especially
the restaurants in Tokyo
are offering more vegan
or vegetarian meals
because there is more Japanese people
and non-Japanese people
who are vegan or vegetarian
compared to other places in Japan.
But overall, the vegan
or vegetarian option
is still limited in Japan.
And in the US, we have
the Impossible Whopper.
What's the difference?
Well, the Impossible burger
has all these ingredients.
So as you can see, a lot more.
I am curious.
That looks like meat, right?
Tastes exactly like a Whopper.
I don't think I would
notice the difference.
They're covering the
lack of meat with, like,
with that char flavor
that they have on there.
Oh, it's good.
In Japan, we call this burger
crispy chicken burger.
And in the US, we have
the before-mentioned
Ch'King sandwich,
which comes in varieties
of spicy and/or deluxe.
For breakfast, our hash
brown comes in one big piece.
Whereas in the US,
our hash browns come in little bites.
And in Japan, we have this cheese bites.
Look at this.
And in the US, we have
eight-piece cheesy tots.
And on to the US breakfast exclusives.
As you can see, we have
a lot more going on
in our breakfast menu here
in the US than Japan has.
Here in the US, you can
get your breakfast sandwich
in biscuit or Croissan'wich options.
Croissan'wich is, of course,
a croissant sandwich.
Took those two words, put
them together. Croissan'wich.
So we have bacon, egg, and cheese;
ham, egg, and cheese;
and sausage, egg, and cheese.
We have two breakfast burritos.
The Egg-Normous breakfast burrito,
which I'm assuming is this one,
'cause it is enormous.
The breakfast burrito junior.
Look at this little guy!
French toast sticks.
Who doesn't like French toast?
Finally, pancake platter
with just three pancakes
or a pancake platter with three pancakes
and a side of sausage.
The fries at Burger King in
Japan come in three sizes,
small,
medium,
and large.
Fries in the US at Burger
King come in four sizes,
value, small, medium, or large.
Or maybe it's value, small, medium, large.
Does this look right?
Any of you "Food Wars" heads
would've seen the Burger
King US vs UK episode
where we uncovered Frygate.
Two sizes had pretty much
the exact same unit of fries.
Now, as you can see from these,
I can't tell which is
the value and the small.
I'm assuming this is the medium.
Well, unfortunately, we cannot
do that amazingly accurate
scientific test that we
did in the last episode
because the fries have been compromised.
They all came in the same bag, and ...
I think they knew what we were up to
and they purposely dumped
all the fries in the same bag
to contaminate the experiment.
You've outsmarted us this time.
George: Let's weigh the large fries
to see how much you actually get.
151 grams.
What if we did a thing where, like,
whatever lands and stays on counts as it?
Does that seem like a fair thing to say?
That's really smart, what
I just did there, I think.
It's 195 grams.
Let's weigh Japan's Whopper.
250 grams.
Joe: And let us weigh
our Whopper in the US.
Yo!
270?
Yeah, 270 grams.
So pretty close. Surprisingly close.
If you're not feeling like having beef,
Burger King also has some chicken options.
You can order your chicken nuggets
in five pieces and eight pieces.
Here in the US, you can
get your nuggets in sizes
of four pieces, eight
pieces, or 16 pieces.
And it's worth noting that
you can only get the 16-piece
online or through their
app, and even if you do,
they still just give you two eight-pieces.
I don't know why either.
So, let's weigh eight-piece nuggets.
130 grams.
Divide by eight equals
16.25 grams per nugget.
I don't know if we can get
as accurate of a measurement
for something so small.
So we will use this guy instead.
So I'll just do this
and put this scale here.
Ah!
This is a bad idea.
Eight pieces is 104 grams,
divided by eight is 13 grams.
In Japan, we have three drink sizes,
small
and medium
and large.
In the US, we have four drink sizes.
Value, which only comes with a value meal;
small; medium; and large.
Now, I want to note that
the US's largest drink size
is 112% larger than Japan's largest drink.
Now, what's the biggest meal
you can get in Japan's Burger King?
Over here, it's the King Meal.
[singing "Circle of Life"]
The King Meal ranges anywhere
from 790 to 990 yen
depending on the burger you choose.
It has your choice of an avocado Whopper,
double cheeseburger, or Whopper.
We chose the double cheeseburger,
which comes with small fries,
five-piece nuggets,
medium Coke, and apple pie.
And in the US, currently
our single biggest menu item
at a Burger King is the
$30 Ultimate Party Bundle.
Now, you could only
order this party bundle
through the BK app, and
it includes two Whoppers,
two double cheeseburgers,
two original chicken sandwiches,
two eight-piece chicken nuggets,
four small fries, and four small drinks.
And it costs:
$30.
In Japan, a Whopper cheese set,
it costs around 890 yen, or $7.80 US.
Whereas in the US, the same meal
with a small fry and drink is $9.29,
or 1,059.65 Japanese yen.
What about the medium?
You get that with the
medium fry and medium drink,
it's $10.29,
or 1,173.71 Japanese yen.
What about the large?
Poof! Hey, there it is,
right in front of me.
Large fries and drink, $11.29,
or 1,287.78 Japanese yen.
Let's look at calories.
In Japan, a Whopper is 676 calories.
The calories aren't too bad,
but watch out for the sodium levels.
One Japan Whopper is 113%
of your daily recommended
amount of sodium.
Too much!
In the US, our Whopper is 667 calories.
Both Whoppers are pretty comparable
in most of the categories,
but there's one statistic
that really stands out,
the salt content.
The sodium level in Japan's
Whopper is 122% higher
than that in the US.
Let's make that a meal.
A Whopper with large
fries and a large Coke
is 1,323 calories.
And the same meal in the
US is 1,680 calories,
so a lot more.
Now, a big portion of the calories
actually come from the large Coke.
The US's is roughly 182% more calories
than that of Japan's.
Let's look at the highest-calorie sandwich
at Japan's Burger King.
The double Whopper cheese is here.
Eating one of these is already
half of your daily calories
and a little over your
daily recommended protein.
The main thing to watch
out for here is the sodium,
which is 152% of your
daily recommended value.
Whereas in the US, our
highest-calorie sandwich
is the spicy chicken
deluxe sandwich, seen here.
If you're worried about your health,
steer clear of this one.
The fat content is 190%
your daily allowance,
and the sodium is over 200%
of your daily allowance.
Yikes.
As I mentioned earlier,
the biggest menu item is the King Meal.
If you get it with a
double bacon cheeseburger,
the total calories are 1,329.
That's 66% of your daily calories.
And, of course, the $30
Ultimate Party Bundle,
which is 8,903 calories,
or 445% your daily
caloric allowance.
Burger King in Japan doesn't disclose
the exact ingredients,
but it does disclose where
the ingredients come from
and where they're finished processing.
For example, the Whopper beef patties
are sourced from Australia,
New Zealand, and Europe,
but they are processed in Australia,
Japan, and Austria.
Burger King in the US is pretty vague
when it comes to its ingredients.
They don't disclose a
comprehensive list anywhere.
At the end of 2020,
Burger King permanently
banned 120 artificial flavors
from their menu, including aluminum,
yellows 1 through 5, BHA, and BHT.
Here's the complete list.
It was actually a lot of stuff.
Good for you guys.
George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Wendy's in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, our Wendy's hamburgers
come in four sizes:
junior, single, double, and triple.
In the US, our burgers come in four sizes:
junior, Dave's single,
Dave's double, and the Dave's triple.
Look at the size of this thing.
In Japan, our nuggets come
in orders of five and 10.
Our US nuggets come in four, six,
and 10-piece.
Our Wendy's drinks come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
And in the US we also
have three drink sizes,
small, medium,
you've gotta be kidding me.
Look at the size of this thing.
This might be 40 ounces, Yuelei.
Only one way to find out.
Ho!
Oh, not quite 40.
About 36 or 37 fluid ounces of Coca-Cola.
And how big's a bladder?
This looks like more
than I would normally pee
in the morning.
OK, let's measure our large drink.
It measures exactly 500 milliliters.
Our Wendy's fries come in two sizes.
Small and medium.
Our fries come in four sizes,
junior, small, medium,
pew, large.
Let's weigh our largest.
[laughs]
Roughly 180 grams.
It weighs 135 grams.
Japan's chili comes in two sizes,
medium and large.
And the US, our chili comes in two sizes,
small and large.
Let us weigh the largest now.
Including the paper cup, 430 grams.
George: Let's weigh our large chili.
265 grams.
In Japan, a Wendy's burger USA double
is 730 yen, or $6.38.
Our US Dave's double goes for $5.99,
or around 685 Japanese yen.
That's a 6.16% decrease
in price in the US.
Let's make it a meal.
In Japan, if you're getting
your burger as a set,
it includes a small fries
and a three-piece nuggets and a drink.
It costs around 440 yen more.
Our meals only include fries and drink.
So a small Dave's double meal,
and I threw in a four-piece
because we don't have a three-piece,
works out to $10.98.
That's an 8.12% increased cost in the US.
Mind you, we did get an extra nugget.
Speaking of nuggets, in Japan,
10-piece nugget is 510 yen,
which breaks down to 51 yen per nugget.
In the US, a 10-piece nugget is $4.29,
which makes it per nugget around 43 cents.
So per nugget average,
the US is paying 8.11% less.
A Baconator double in Japan
is 850 yen, or $7.43.
In the US, you get that
same Baconator for $7.49,
or 857 Japanese yen.
So close. Only a 0.82% increase.
Here is everything you can
get at the Wendy's in Japan
you cannot get in the US.
And here's everything at a US Wendy's
you can't get in Japan.
One thing I want to point
out is that in Japan,
Wendy's is known as Wendy's First Kitchen.
First Kitchen is a
Japanese fast-food chain,
and it was acquired by Wendy's in 2016
and became a hybrid of Wendy's
and First Kitchen's menus.
And we call them Fakkin,
which is the abbreviation of First Kitchen
in a Japanese way.
It's like First Kitchen's "Fa"
and kitchen's "ki" and "n."
And say: Fakkin.
Repeat after me: Fakkin.
[beep]
Got it, buddy.
Very good!
So, here are our Japan's
exclusive burgers.
So, this one is bacon mushroom melt,
and this one is just mushroom melt.
We have Wendy's bacon egg burger.
We also have Wendy's
cheese bacon egg burger,
and this sauce,
tartar sauce. Umai.
Everybody's curious what this is.
This one is Wild Rock.
It's got no buns.
It's got two beef patties.
I think I should try this one.
Itadakimasu.
This meat itself has a good taste
and some kind of, like, peppery flavor,
but it's a little bit dry.
I wouldn't get this again.
And last things,
we have junior teriyaki burger,
and we have junior teriyaki cheeseburger.
The big bacon cheeseburger.
The big bacon double.
Look at this! Yep, one, two,
three, the big bacon triple.
I mean, I don't know what angle
is best to look at this at.
And then we got big
bacons on the fancy bread.
This must be the big bacons classicses.
This looks like a big bacon --
look, it's got shredded
cheese and stuff on this.
Everything's bacon
something with these guys.
At this point, it's just
like, how many slabs of meat
do you want on your bacon sandwich?
Two things you can get at a Wendy's
in the US you cannot get in Japan
or just the junior burger
and the junior cheeseburger.
Look at this little guy. Look at this.
Literally every fast-food burger place
has a version of this.
Chicken!
[grunts]
The Asiago chicken sandwiches.
We got the Asiago chicken
ranch classic club.
I said that in the wrong
order, but you get what I mean.
Probably this one.
This is the fried Asiago club with bacon.
And then there is the spicy,
which I'm assuming is this one.
And then they got the grilled.
That's pretty good.
Don't like Asiago?
Wendy's got you covered.
So many chicken sandwiches at Wendy's
that of course are not Asiago'd.
This is the grilled chicken sandwich.
As you can see, it is grilled.
And then we have the
grilled chicken big bacon.
Man, they must've gotten some
deal on bacon for Wendy's.
Everything's got bacon on it!
I'm going to go ahead
and assume this is the
big bacon fried chicken sandwich,
'cause it has bacon on it.
So you have the spicy big
bacon cheddar chicken.
In Japan, our Wendy's have pasta,
which were originally on
the First Kitchen menu.
So here we have
ramen-style soy cream pasta
with spinach and ham.
Expires 2023,
January 20.
Joe, I'll keep this for you.
Nah, my guy, you can go
ahead and throw that out.
And next we have ramen-style
dandan soup pasta
with spinach and ham.
So, dandan soup is kind of like
a spicy chili-flavored soup
with miso and pork mince.
Dandan soup and dandan ramen
are very popular in Japan.
Tomato sauce pasta
with mozzarella and bacon.
All right, next we have beef
cheek meat cream spaghetti.
Plastic.
Mm.
Next we have carbonara spaghetti.
Naotomo: Carbon-AR-a.
Carbon-AAH-ra.
Carbona-rrra.
A-rrra? OK.
Carbra-rrra.
[crew laughing]
It's got bacon
and this creamy carbona-rrra sauce.
Molto bene!
Last thing I have is
spicy cod roe spaghetti.
So, spicy cod roe in Japanese is mentaiko,
and mentaiko spaghetti is
also very popular in Japan.
Unfortunately, some Americans I know
don't like mentaiko so much
because of the texture and smell.
But for me, mentaiko,
it's super Fakkin delicious.
Uh, it's been a while
since I got this one.
It's been, like, three hours.
Itadakimasu.
Mm.
Joe, try it out.
I appreciate the offer, George,
but you can go ahead and finish that,
'cause it looks Fakkin disgusting.
We got salads.
Over here on this end, the first one
looks like we got the
Parmesan Caesar salad.
Comes with, of course, Caesar dressing
and what looks to be Parmesan crisps.
This next salad is ridiculous.
We're going to go ahead and
put quotes around salad.
Wendy's has a taco "salad" that comes
with tortilla chips, sour
cream, signature salsa,
and, if that wasn't enough, chili.
And before we continue,
you confirmed that the taco salad
is supposed to have chili on it?
They told you that.
Just gotta get the chips all around here.
I can't believe this.
This is so gross.
Signature salsa, then chili.
Oh, it smells so bad.
Oh, God.
Eh.
I'm just -- this is just like eating chili
with tortilla chips.
They said there was some salt --
I'm just pushing this s--- around.
On to the next salad,
the Southwest avocado salad.
Oh, my God, there's bacon on it!
That's weird.
That was in Dave Thomas' obituary.
"I want everything to
be covered in bacon."
But yeah. Chicken, avocado,
bacon, cheese, and some sauce.
This makes sense.
And the last salad,
apple pecan salad.
That smells.
Oh, 'cause it's got blue cheese on it.
Roasted pecan bits.
Pomegranate vinaigrette!
Mm. Apples are nice.
It's kind of nice to get a
little bit of actual fruit,
something nutritious while doing this.
It's like my body's like, "What is this?!"
So, here are Japan's side menu.
We have a few flavor options for fries.
So we have happy butter flavor fries.
Happy butter flavor.
It has just subtle buttery flavor. Mm.
Burnt butter soy sauce flavor.
Rip it off. Bwah!
I don't know what's going on
here, but it's pretty good.
Much better than this.
Savory steamed potato butter.
It gets quite strong buttery flavor.
Definitely I prefer this one
than the happy butter flavor.
This is not happy.
This one is chicken consommé flavor.
Mm.
This is the best fries
I've ever had in my life.
Now I'm going to introduce you
this spicy chicken breast.
Wendy's in the US also has baked potatoes.
See what we got.
Of course, there's your regular.
And this one, oh, yeah.
This one's got, like,
chives and stuff in it.
If I was to stop here, you would go,
"Wow, what a tasteful
selection of healthy potatoes."
But of course we don't stop here.
We move on to absolute
baked-potato madness.
Ah, No. 1, oof.
Cheese baked potato.
Drowned this thing in cheese.
It's like -- ooh!
It's, like, caked to the side. Blech.
Ugh. Ugh.
Oh, God! [laughs]
The chili and cheese baked potato.
Blech.
If you are like me, you're
wondering to yourself,
something's missing.
Something is missing from
this potato menu, Yuelei!
Can you guess what that is?
The bacon cheese baked potato!
Oh, they got big pieces
of bacon on this one too.
Oof!
You can get spicy chicken nuggets.
Yessiree Bob.
Seasoned potatoes.
All right, so fruit finally made the menu.
Apple slices.
It wouldn't be a Wendy's category
without the Baconator fries.
We need the bacon meter in this episode.
Last of the sides.
Oh, yeah.
Oatmeal bar.
Looks like a Clif bar.
Whoa, that's actually pretty good.
So, here are our Japan's exclusive drinks.
We have tapioca royal
milk tea with brown sugar
and tapioca milk with brown sugar.
Tornado.
Mm!
This is amazing.
Simply amazing.
I love this.
So, here are our other drinks.
We have Pepsi, orange juice,
and ginger ale,
lemonade and melon soda,
peach tea and iced tea,
iced matcha, and this one is iced cocoa.
So, here we have our hot drinks.
We have Darjeeling tea,
and we have café mocha,
and we have peach tea.
Mm.
I like this.
And we have café latte
and cocoa
and matcha.
This is matcha, but it looks like
water from 100 years ago.
Our Wendy's has Frosty-ccinos,
which I'm assuming are
Frostys meet Frappuccinos?
Frosty-ccinos?
But it does not appear that
there's Frostys in this.
They have two flavors,
vanilla and chocolate.
I'm assuming this is the vanilla.
Wendy's did smart on this
one. It isn't that sweet.
I was expecting it to
be, like, undrinkable,
but it's actually kind of nice.
All right, this one is the chocolate.
Yeah.
Also, it's a nice flavor.
'Cause of the Frosty-ccinos,
you know what that means.
At Wendy's you can also get:
booyah, Frostys.
They don't have these in Japan?
I feel like this is the staple menu item.
[laughs]
I love these so much.
Fantastic. That's fantastic.
Gotta go for the chocolate.
Don't bother finding me a spoon.
I'm just gonna do a little taste here.
That's great.
The Frostys are great.
It's like a milkshake, but
it's super thick and delicious.
Japan, you want this.
Thick.
It is thick!
In Japan, we have floats
instead of Frostys.
We have Coke float
and melon soda float.
Japan has an exclusive breakfast sandwich.
It's called the breakfast sandwich.
It's got tomato, lettuce,
and I believe this is
beef or pork patties.
OK, whereas Japan has one
exclusive breakfast sandwich,
we have way more.
Like all the fast food here in America,
we take our breakfast very seriously.
You can get yourself a
maple bacon croissant.
It looks like it's a chicken sandwich
that of course has bacon and
maple syrup on the croissant.
We have what just appears
to be the bacon biscuit.
Bacon, egg, cheese
in the incredibly dry biscuit.
Bacon croissant.
I don't know about this one.
Moving on to the sausage zone
of the Wendy's breakfast.
This is the special sausage biscuit.
No, no, no, no, no.
Here's what I hate about this.
Pick a drier thing to have for breakfast.
I feel like it'd be impossible
to swallow a bite of this.
You're going to choke on it.
Here we go. See, this is
what I'm talking about.
They might have gotten this backwards.
This is actually the better sausage one.
This at least has a better chance
of not getting stuck in your throat.
The sausage croissant
also has egg. Thank you.
They have a few things that
are honey-butter-based.
I am so glad that fast-food places
are introducing honey
to their breakfast menu.
I think maybe it has to do with the fact
that chicken sandwiches
have become so popular.
First one we got here is
the honey butter biscuit.
[laughs]
Hey, it's just a biscuit
with honey butter.
I mean, yeah, I'll have this anytime.
I'll have this anytime.
This one has some heft to it.
It's the hot honey biscuit.
Yeah!
A little chicken on there.
Yep.
I really like that.
This is the special chicken croissant.
So, here are our desserts.
So here we have Melotozzo.
So, Melotozzo are
maritozzo-style pastries,
which are popular in
Rome and Japan as well,
made with melon bread.
So melon bread is a type
of sweet Japanese bread
which has a sugar cookie
crust on the surface.
But what's funny is that
it doesn't have a melon flavor at all.
At all.
The reason it's called melon bread
is that it just looks like melon.
Does it look like melon?
It does in Japan.
Oh!
And this time,
First Kitchen made a
maritozzo using melon bread
and mascarpone cheese whipped cream,
and it's called Melotozzo.
So here we have Melotozzo tiramisu
and Melotozzo matcha and Melotozzo plain.
So, actually, yesterday was
my birthday, February 18.
Hey, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday, George!
Thank you for your message!
Thank you! Arigatou gozaimasu!
So this is my birthday present.
All right, so let's give it a shot.
Best birthday present ever.
Itadakimasu.
This is so good.
I can't stop eating this.
Mm.
So, Wendy's in Japan has a
Japanese traditional sweet
since it has been a
collaboration with First Kitchen.
So we have shiratama cream zenzai.
Ooh.
So it has three main
ingredients, ice cream,
and sweet red beans, and the shiratama,
which is kind of like a mochi rice cake.
And my grandma likes this type of zenzai.
This is for you, my grandma.
And also we have mini pancakes.
In the US, we only have
two exclusive desserts,
and they're both cookies.
And that's no disrespect to cookies,
cookies are great, but I want one of those
fun Italian ice cream sandwiches they had.
Anyway, you can get two
cookies here in the US,
a chocolate chunk cookie
and a sugar cookie.
Our Wendy's double burger is 578 calories
and 29% of your daily recommended amount
and 60% of the recommended daily sodium.
Our double burger, the Dave's
double, isn't much better.
Ours is 850 calories
and way more fat. Over 70%!
But less sodium,
just a bit over half of the daily amount.
Still, not great.
Make it a meal in Japan,
and that increases the calories to 1,089.
That's 55% of your daily
recommended calorie intake.
And if you make it a combo
here, we chose the small
and took a few sips,
that's 440 more calories,
bringing the total to 1,290,
or 64.5% of your daily allowance.
In Japan, the single menu
item with the most calories
is the eight-piece fried-chicken pack,
which contains [gasps] 4,018 calories,
201% of your daily calories.
In the US, our single
biggest-calorie menu item
is the Feed the Fam deal.
A fam, yeah, right! This is all for you.
It is two spicy chicken sandwiches,
two junior bacon cheeseburgers,
and four small fries.
Total 2,780 calories,
which is 139% of your daily intake.
Japan's Wendy's doesn't
disclose their ingredients list.
Why, Japan?
The US sure does.
Now, is there anything we
should be looking out for?
Of course there is.
Let's start with sodium nitrate,
which is found in the Baconator's
applewood-smoked bacon.
Sodium nitrate is a chemical
that is used to cure meats
and gives meat that appealing pink color.
Perfect for bacon.
Also, get this,
it's super toxic.
It is restricted for purchase online.
People have accidentally
eaten too much of it and died.
It's also been used in homicides. Yikes!
Sodium nitrate is on a list
of Japan's designated food additives,
but our Wendy's gets its
bacon imported from Denmark,
where it isn't banned,
but being reduced in use.
Our American cheese contains lecithin,
a common emulsifier that,
according to one academic,
a worrisome number of scientific
studies have suggested
that too much of it
can promote depression.
[sighs]
The pickles contain polysorbate 80.
This is commonly used as
an emulsifier in foods,
but in pickles, it tends to
be used as a solubilizer.
Not how that's pronounced, sorry.
Which helps other ingredients
in the brine fully dissolve.
Studies have suggested it can
cause colon cancer in mice.
Not fantastic.
There is no info on Wendy's website
of where the pickles come from,
but we want to point
out that polysorbate 80
is on Japan's list of
designated additives.
And therefore, it's permitted
to be used in Japan.
George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Domino's in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, Domino's pizzas
come in three sizes.
Our Domino's pizza comes in four sizes.
George: So, this one is medium,
which is cut into 8 slices.
Joe: Over here on this
end, you got the small.
That's 10-inch pizza.
And here's regular, which is
also cut into eight slices.
Joe: Next up is our medium.
That's a 12-inch pizza.
And this one is large.
This one is cut into 12 slices.
Joe: Then we move to our large, 14 inches.
And finally, the extra
large, which is 16 inches.
Look at all that grease.
A Domino's large plain pizza
has a 33-centimeters diameter
or an 855.3-square-centimeters area
and costs 2,000 yen.
So breaking that down,
our pizza is 2.33 yen per square inch,
or about 2 cents.
Now take our large.
This is a 14-inch pizza,
also a 35.56-centimeter pizza.
And it has a surface area
of 993.1 square centimeters.
That's 1.4 cents per square inch,
or 1.62 Japanese yen.
But what gives you the
most food for your money?
So, here's a large plain
slice with a pan crust.
And here's another with hand-tossed crust.
Let's weigh both right
now and see which is more.
So, first let's weigh pan crust.
51 grams.
And hand-tossed crust.
It weighs 49 grams.
And we will do the same.
I want to note that right now in America,
you can only get the pan
Domino's in the medium size.
Same exact experiment, only
I'm doing two medium pizzas.
Medium pan slice, medium
hand-tossed slice.
So, this is the hand-tossed slice,
and it weighs
a smidge over 75.
We'll go 76.
The pan.
That goes in there too.
110 grams.
Making the difference this amount.
I'm not doing math.
In Japan, we have seven
different crust options.
No. 1, we have pan.
And No. 2 we have hand-tossed.
And No. 3, we have ultra-crispy.
Ooh.
It's like a cracker.
No. 4, we have cheese burst,
where a string cheese is placed
around the edge of the crust
and sprinkled with consommé
Parmesan seasoning.
Ooh.
No. 5, we have the cheese 'n' roll.
It's got mozzarella cheese in the crust.
And No. 6, we have mille-filet.
Or mill-foy.
Mille-fail.
In Japanese we say mi-ru fi-yu.
So this one is mi-ru-fi-yu pizza,
which has two layers of crust
with Camembert mixed cheese in between.
Mille-fail.
Mille-fee-yuh.
French people, please
correct my pronunciation.
No. 7, the last one we have,
the triple mille-feuille.
It's got three layers of
crust with cheese in between.
Wow.
In the US, we have only
five crust options.
I realize there's four
pizzas in front of me.
Let me explain.
One crust option you can get here,
and it's a small only,
is the gluten-free crust.
I don't know how bread is gluten-free,
but we figured it out.
Ta-da.
We also have the hand-tossed,
which is more of a standard pillowy,
I mean, right, this is
like standard dough,
this is what we think a pizza looks like.
This is the pan.
Look how thick that is, man.
That's, like, triple the dough thickness.
Good on you for the pan.
Now, you can get this in the medium only.
We also have a crunchy thin crust.
And we have so many
pizzas here, to be honest,
I don't know which one it is.
So when it just comes up in
the video, I'll show it off.
But imagine a crunchy thin pizza.
Oddly enough, we also
have something called
the Brooklyn-style pizza.
This is reserved for large
and extra-large pizzas only.
And this is a Brooklyn-style
right here, extra large.
Obviously it isn't crispy,
because it's sagging.
This is really thin.
Here's everything you can
get at the Japanese Domino's
that you cannot get in the US.
Here's everything you
can get at a US Domino's
you cannot get in Japan.
Everyone, look at this.
This is a limited-time-offer pizza.
It's called the Best 34.
Look at this lid.
It's disgusting!
Don't look at me! Don't look at me!
So, this one has all 34 Domino's toppings,
like teriyaki chicken, mayo,
spinach, tomato, shrimp.
This is huge.
It's like my baby.
[sings lullaby]
The New Yorker-style pizza is similar
to the Brooklyn XL option
you can get in America.
But only in Japan you can
get the Quattro New Yorker.
It's a 16-inch pizza with
each New Yorker topping style
covering a quarter of the pizza.
So one quarter is pepperoni,
and one is cheese,
and one is pepperoni and sausage,
and one is ham and mushroom.
So, here we have Nippon favorites series.
Nippon, or Nihon, means Japan in Japanese.
So these pizzas feature
Japanese ingredients.
This one charcoal-grilled
teriyaki chicken.
It's got teriyaki chicken, teriyaki sauce,
spinach, mayonnaise, and corn.
Next we have Hokkaido three cheeses.
So, Hokkaido is the northern
island prefecture in Japan,
and it's famous for its cheese.
It's got Hokkaido Gouda cheese,
Hokkaido cheddar cheese,
and Hokkaido Camembert
and sliced asparagus.
We have spicy mayo and mochi.
It's got mochi rice cake and corn,
pork sausage and sliced asparagus,
and Korean seaweed flakes.
And last one, we've got
charcoal-grilled beef
and spinach and mushrooms.
Mm!
Oh!
Umai!
This beef is so tender,
and it's got so much,
like, charcoal flavor,
which makes this amazing.
I love this.
So many exclusive pizzas
here at the US Domino's.
I don't know where to begin,
so I'll just start with
this one that I'm holding.
This is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
I don't know what makes it
California-in-y or Cali-y,
but it definitely has
chicken, and bacon, and ranch,
and it's big.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Chicken taco pizza.
Oh, yeah.
Got taco spices to it.
Good job on this one.
Next one, the cheeseburger pizza.
Um ...
Yeah. Oh, my God.
I'm going to say something crazy.
This tastes exactly like
a McDonald's cheeseburger.
Even has the oniony
and the ketchupy taste.
Wow.
That is a surprise.
I thought this one was going to be bad,
but it's actually pretty good.
The extravaganZZa.
This has pepperoni, sausage, ham,
mushrooms, black olives, green peppers.
This is the meatZZa,
which I'm assuming is just a lot of meat.
I'm seeing sausage, I'm seeing pepperoni,
and maybe hamburger.
Yeah, I'll put this in the good pile.
I f--- with this one.
Philly cheesesteak.
Oh, no.
In some weird way, I'm
blaming you for this.
Since you handed this to
me, this is your fault.
Look at this nightmare.
Meat somewhere on here.
I'm also seeing green peppers.
Oh. Look, look, it's like,
look at that, it's,
like, stuck to the box.
No.
Buffalo chicken.
OK, OK.
This is more my speed.
Chicken.
No, not tomato sauce, like a white sauce.
Good call.
Mm!
This isn't Buffalo enough.
The capital of the great state of New York
needs to be better
represented in this pizza.
The capital of New York
is Buffalo, correct?
No?
We got the Memphis barbecue chicken.
Love Memphis.
Love barbecue.
Love chicken.
Yeah.
The key thing here is the barbecue sauce.
I don't know what is in it,
but, man, that's really good.
Memphis,
capital of the great state of Tennessee.
Everyone, here is the
ultra cheese New Yorker.
It's got 1 kilogram of cheese,
or 2.2 pounds.
OMG.
Ooh!
Look how thick this cheese is!
Go!
Go home.
It weighs 180 grams,
180 times eight equals
1,440 grams in total.
So, here are other
Japanese specialty pizzas.
So, here we have quattro meat max.
So it's got charcoal-grilled
teriyaki chicken
and charcoal-grilled beef
and giga meat and Goryeo galbi.
It's Korean-style beef pizza.
And next we have seafood special.
This part and this part
is shrimp mayonnaise.
So this part, it's got shrimp, octopus,
mussels, littleneck clams,
Mactra clams, green peppers,
and cherry tomatoes.
Next we've got garlic master.
Looks so spicy.
Garlic and pork sausage and pancetta.
And this part has got jalapeño, obviously.
It's picante.
Pepperoni and Italian sausage and onions.
And look at this huge thing.
Mayo jaga.
So, jaga, or jagaimo,
means potato in Japanese.
It's got potato and pork sausage
and a lot of mayo.
Joe: Our US Domino's has
sandwiches and pasta.
I was not a fan of the
Philly cheesesteak pizza,
but let's see what the Philly
cheesesteak tastes like
in its native form of sandwich.
Better than the pizza.
Also at the US Domino's,
you can get a Buffalo chicken sandwich,
a chicken habanero sandwich,
the Mediterranean veggie,
no, thanks,
a chicken bacon ranch,
an Italian sandwich,
and, of course, the chicken Parm sandwich.
Our Domino's has four
pastas to choose from.
I only got two, the chicken Alfredo
and the Italian sausage marinara.
You can also get a chicken
carbonara and a pasta primavera.
I've just been informed
I have to eat this.
Strong flavor on this.
I would skip the pasta
at Domino's, personally.
This thing is, like, baked on.
See how baked this is?
Like, come on.
I feel like chef Ramsay here.
Just, "Oh, come on. Oh,
this baked on here!"
In the US, we have a few chicken options
you can't get in Japan.
Yes, Japan has wings,
but they don't have these flavors.
Visually, I can see why.
First flavor we got here
is the garlic Parmesan.
Hey, Domino's, what are you doing?
Next one, we got,
I'm assuming this is the honey barbecue.
These drizzles! What are you
guys doing drizzling, man?
Just toss it!
Toss it in the sauce!
Nobody wants a drizzle.
Oh, wait a second.
This is the sweet mango habanero.
I wasn't expecting that heat.
Oh, man.
Very good.
These are --
why did you do this?
Why did you do this?
Toss it in the sauce.
Why'd you just squirt it on
here, like, as an afterthought?
Honey barbecue.
Right? Is this not nuts?
This is nuts, right, that
they did it like this.
I like the sauce.
So, Domino's also does their
wings in boneless flavors.
They have obviously those three,
and you can also get these two other ones.
And I see we have the
crispy bacon and tomato,
and this one must be the
spicy jalapeño pineapple.
Whoa, what?
Hell yeah.
All right.
Get that B-roll fast.
There it goes!
I know.
Your audible gasps are warranted.
I don't know what this --
what am I supposed to do with this?
Ooh, this one I'm looking
forward to, Yuelei.
We got the food less than an hour ago.
I don't think an hour is
unrealistic for food to sit.
I think you guys gotta
put some more chemicals
in your cheese to keep it goopier longer.
Ooh, I got some pineapple,
and I got some jalapeño,
and I got some chicken.
Let's check it out.
Yeah.
Overall, everything
here tastes pretty good.
Presentation, you gotta work on that.
In Japan, we don't have boneless wings,
but we have Japanese fried chicken,
which is called karaage.
It kind of looks like
American boneless wings.
Ah.
I love karaage.
And also we have chicken nuggets.
Both come in four, eight, and 12 pieces.
Our Domino's has breads
and oven-baked dips.
Let's review the breads first.
Shall we?
Over here,
we have Parmesan bread twists
and garlic bread twists.
I know that because of their
totally twisted shapes.
They also have Parmesan bread bites
that were currently unavailable.
Whoa.
Uh-oh.
These are very good.
To Parmesan we go.
Not as good.
But still pretty good.
I mean, it's bread and
cheese and oil, right?
US Domino's also has something
called stuffed cheesy bread.
You can get your stuffed
cheesy bread with either
spinach and feta or bacon and jalapeños.
Take a wild guess which one I chose.
[beep] Just ripping this
whole [beep] thing apart.
Oh, God!
This thing is especially greasy.
For whatever reason,
Domino's didn't stop there.
Domino's has something called dips.
[sighs]
What it appears to be
is a giant dish of melted cheese.
And you can get it in cheesy
marinara or five cheese.
What are we doing, Domino's?
[laughs]
What is this?
Come on, guys.
So, this is the marinara
one, I'm assuming.
A pizza without the bread, right?
These dips are literally
zapping my will to live.
Please don't ever get ...
It's a whole bowl of cheese, Yuelei!
Why would -- oh, look
at the oil in this too!
Everyone in here just gagged.
Can I even dip it?
Oh, whoa.
I don't know what of the
five cheeses is in here,
like, which five.
Why am I eating this?!
Ugh!
So, here are our Japanese
exclusive side-menu items.
Let's start with this one.
We've got oven-baked potato wedges.
This one is plain.
Consommé.
Chili garlic.
And this one is butter.
And next we have cheese sticks.
Shrimp popcorn.
It comes with this tartar sauce.
Here we have choregi salad.
We've got Korean-style seaweed flakes
and choregi dressing.
So, choregi is, like,
Korean-style sesame-oil dressing.
And fresh salad in the package.
So, here we have corn potage.
Clam chowder.
Minestrone.
Black chili.
You've seen these before.
It is the Domino's
marbled cookie brownies.
♪ Liquid sugar ♪
Oh, yeah.
You can also get these
cinnamon bread twists.
Lastly, another dip.
I swear to God, if there's cheese in this,
I'm walking out of here
and I'm never coming back.
Baked apple dips.
And I'm assuming you dip these into this.
I'm not gonna.
So, here are our other desserts.
We have mini pancakes,
heart-shaped fondant chocolate,
and here we have egg custard tart.
I have never tried this one before.
Itadakimasu.
Mm.
Mm!
This is so good.
So flaky.
Mm.
This one is apple pie.
And next we have custard pie.
Lastly, of the sodas
you can get in the US,
can't get in Japan,
get yourself Fanta orange and Sprite.
We have Coke Zero.
It's supposed to be Zero,
but they gave us just normal Coke.
Next, we have ginger ale.
Canada Dry.
Canada is an amazing country, eh?
Qoo orange juice.
And here is Sokenbicha.
It's Japanese blended tea.
And last one, we've got Georgia Japan
Craftsman café latte.
Georgia Japan.
Sounds like George Japan.
I'd like to be sponsored by you.
Let me try this.
It's got a lot of milk and sugar in it.
I gotta be honest.
It's not my taste.
Take two.
I really love this.
Please give me a sponsorship.
A Japan large hand-tossed pizza
is 130 calories per slice,
or 1,560 calories for the full pizza.
In the US, a large hand-tossed
pizza slice is 280 calories,
which makes the entire
pizza 2,240 calories.
A large big-pepperoni hand-tossed slice
is 335 calories per slice,
or 4,020 calories for the entire pizza.
Our large pepperoni is
370 calories per slice,
which makes the entire pie 2,960 calories.
Japan's most calorific pizza is
the ultra cheese New Yorker size.
One slice is 478 calories.
That's 3,827 for the full pizza.
Ah.
Our US Domino's pizza
with the most calories
is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
This is an XL of said pizza.
One slice is 560 calories,
and that makes the full
pie 3,360 calories.
Our large plain pizza
has 1,620 calories total.
Our large cheese is 2,240 calories.
That's a 38.2% increase.
Our large big pepperoni is 2,680 calories,
over 34% of your daily
recommended calorie intake.
333% of your daily sodium.
Ah!
Too many tasty calories!
Ours is 2,960 calories,
48% over your daily recommended amount,
but somehow ours has less sodium,
only 299% of your daily sodium.
In October of last year,
a study found detectable
amounts of phthalate,
a plastic softener, in common menu items
from large fast-food
chains, including Domino's.
The study analyzed 64 food samples
from several popular fast-food chains
and found phthalates DnBP and DEHP
in a majority of the items.
USA Today reported that,
"Food containing meat,
such as chicken burritos
and cheeseburgers,
had higher levels of
the chemicals studied,
while cheese pizza had the lowest levels."
OK, so that's good news
for Domino's, I guess.
The study goes on to say
that "food handling gloves
contain replacement plasticizers,
which may be [a] source
of food contamination."
Sounds to me like an easy fix.
Just prepare the food without gloves.
Japan has a ban on DEHP
in food-handling gloves.
Good-er news, if you're
a fan of "Food Wars"
and saw the US versus UK Domino's episode,
we highlighted BHA and
BHT in the US pepperoni.
Well, on the stewardship
page on Domino's website,
they have stated, ahem,
"We have eliminated a long list
of ingredients from all
of our core products
including BHA and BHT and PHOs,
as well as trans-fat from
core pizza products,"
which is fantastic news.
I clearly was going to eat it anyway,
but thank you regardless.
From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pocky in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, our Pocky comes in a 72-gram box
which contains two
packets and a nine-pack.
(Pocky wrapper crinkles)
- Our Pocky's come in
basically three sizes.
The one 1.14-ounce box,
the 2.47-ounce box,
and the 4.13-ounce boxy bag.
But our strawberry-flavored box is smaller
than this chocolate box.
This is a 3.81-ounce box,
which is 0.32 ounces
smaller than this one.
Largest box bag is this,
the Cookies & Cream flavor,
which is 4.57 ounces
or 0.44 grams larger
than the chocolate box.
One theory, my theory,
is that the Pocky boxes
contain a specific number
of Pocky sticks
and each Pocky is a different weight
based on the flavor coating.
So we're gonna weigh
each Pocky individually
to see if this is true.
All right, chocolate first.
So seven of these are 13 grams.
Can someone write that down?
Strawberry, seven is 13 grams.
Was that what the first one was? Okay.
Cookies & Cream!
Cookies & Cream, seven
of them are 18 grams.
Well, the Cookies & Cream ones
are definitely a lot heavier.
A lot heavier.
(Joe chomping)
Mm!
- So let's see how many
Pocky are in a box.
(George counting in Japanese)
(audio chirping)
32, 33, 34.
Thirty-four Pocky in total.
So one packet has 17 Pocky
and another one also has 17 Pocky.
- Let's see how many
Pocky's are in this box.
(Pocky wrapper crinkles)
(exhales) Oh, man.
Is this normal?
I think I can kind of like,
do you wanna get a
close-up on there before?
So one, two, three, those
are the broken ones.
(audio chirping)
30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36.
You know how everyone
was complaining about
how I eat Kit-Kats in the Kit-Kat episode?
(suspenseful music)
(Joe chomps)
(Joe chewing)
Mm!
(upbeat music)
Here's all the Pocky's
that are native to the US
that are not in Japan.
- And here are all the
Pocky's native to Japan.
- Cookies & Cream, Cookies & Cream.
Not a solid block, so that's good.
(Pocky wrapper crinkles)
(Joe chomping)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mm!
I like those.
This looks like fun, Yuelei.
Chocolate Banana, have
you had these before?
You have?
No, mm-mm.
That banana flavor hits right away.
Oh, no.
Matcha green tea.
Any "Food Wars" heads watching know,
Joe does not like matcha.
Mm, smells like a freshly-cut lawn.
(lawnmower rumbles)
(Joe chomps)
Yeah, nah.
There's also a Crunchy Strawberry
flavor you can get here
in the US,
but I was not able to get my hands on it
by the time of filming this episode.
So here's just regular strawberry.
Uh-oh.
Oh, another solid block.
Yeah.
(Joe chomps)
(audience gasps)
Mm, yeah, dude.
Put me in jail for crimes against Pocky's.
- George's energy.
Bong, let's go!
All right, let's start with this one.
We have Pocky Luxury Milk Chocolate.
(laughs) Is it Pocky?
You look like corn dog.
What happened to you?
Hmm.
It's got milk and fermented butter flavor.
And we have another corn dog.
It's a Almond Milk flavor.
(George speaks in Japanese)
Mm.
It has strong almond milk flavor.
I prefer this one, the milk chocolate,
but both are so short.
You should be longer.
(whistle screeches)
You too!
We have this ultra-thin Pocky.
Oh. (laughs)
You are so thin this time.
This one is short.
This one is so thin.
We have Tasty.
Why is it Tasty?
Oh, fermented butter
is used for this stick.
Ooh.
(George chomps)
It's got just a little
bit of butter flavor.
I still prefer this one, this corn dog.
Almond Crush.
It's a little different.
Look at the packets.
Yeah, obviously, it's got almonds.
Okey-dokey, Pocky.
(George speaks in Japanese)
I love this.
Mm.
We've got Pocky Chocolate Coconut.
Oh, this one is also
this style of packets.
Oh.
It's pretty similar with
this one, Almond Crush.
(George chomps)
Hmm?
Yeah, obviously, it's got coconut flavor,
and also, it's got a
little bit of saltiness.
It's not my taste.
Strawberry chocolate Pocky.
(George chomps)
Oh.
Ah.
Right after you bite this,
you get some sweetness.
But after that, you get sourness.
It smells so strong.
I can smell it from here.
Cocoa powder Pocky,
And it says you can only
get this in winter season.
Oh yeah, look at this.
It's got cocoa powder.
(George speaks in Japanese)
(George's lips smack)
We've got the cutest Pocky ever.
Cherry heart-shaped Pocky.
Aha.
Oh, look at this!
Heart! It's in there.
How cute.
And this part, cherry
chocolate is so awesome.
You get strong cherry flavor.
We've also got blueberry
heart-shaped chocolate Pocky.
(Pocky wrapper crinkles)
Ooh, look at this.
So blue.
This color doesn't make me want
to eat this, but let's try.
(George speaks in Japanese)
Ooh!
Mm.
So sour.
But look at this heart-shaped Pocky.
Not for me.
This is what I've been
waiting for, sakura matcha.
So "sakura" means cherry blossom.
Cherry blossom matcha taste.
Ooh.
Look at this!
So it's got matcha chocolate
and this stick is pink.
(George chomps)
Mm, this is so Japanese-y Pocky.
Just sweet matcha.
The feeling of spring has come to my life.
(bird chirping)
Spring days here in my body.
(George sings in Japanese)
Everybody's curious what these are.
Megami no Ruby.
Otona no Kohaku.
What does it mean?
I don't even know. (laughs)
Anyway, so it says Megami no Ruby.
It means like, "Goddess Ruby".
Otona no Kohaku, in
English, it says, "amber."
Kind of like stone, fossil, jewel.
It says it goes well with red wine.
Interesting.
Ta-da!
It looks like regular chocolate Pocky.
(George chomps)
Oh?
What is this?
This taste itself is like berries.
This one goes well with whiskey.
(George chomps)
Huh?
It's pretty close to dark
chocolate, it's bitter.
In Japan, we have this
Gokuboso extra-fine Pocky,
which are roughly half the thickness
of a regular chocolate Pocky.
- In the US, ours are
called the Ultra Slim.
- I got a new digital scale.
What I'm gonna do is weigh
a regular chocolate Pocky.
2.13 grams.
So ultra thin Pocky.
So it weighs 1.52 grams.
- Thinner, that's it?
Here's a big boy.
Here's the thin.
Is it able to do this?
Can I get out of the way so
it's just the white background?
23, 24, 25, and there's another
bag in here, so 50 per box.
Okay, so 50 instead of 36.
Seven regular Pocky's are 13 grams.
Let's see how many slim ones
we needed to get to 13 grams.
5, 6, 7, 8 1/2.
Eight and a half slim ones are the same
as seven regular ones.
Is that that much slimmer?
I guess that's slimmer.
Does anyone think that's
not significant enough
to be a selling point?
Pocky adjusts its sweetness
for different countries.
Not surprisingly, the US
ones are meant to be sweeter.
I'm gonna do a taste test side by side.
We got the American ones
and the Japanese one,
and we're gonna see just
how different they taste.
I'm worried that these are
also gonna be a Pocky popsicle.
Oh no, okay.
Japanese.
These are only Japanese ones I can find.
Obviously, they're bigger. I
don't know if this is the norm.
(Joe chomps)
Mm-hm, in the baseline sweetness.
Yeah.
Mm.
(Joe chomps)
Yeah, it's noticeably different.
They taste identical, but
ours has a sweet aftertaste.
I like the Japanese ones much better.
- So Pocky is in the Guinness
World Records three times.
It's the largest
chocolate-coated biscuits brand,
has the most mentions of a brand name
on Twitter in 24 hours,
which was 3,710,044 times.
And finally, it was part
of the most people opening
packaged food online
simultaneously with 143 people.
- 143 people, that's it?
That doesn't seem like that many.
I feel like I've been on Zoom work calls
with 143 people in it, right?
It would've been literally
one email to set that up.
- I can do (George speaks in Japanese).
Pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom-pom.
Now I got more than 200
George's clones right here.
Simultaneously, three, two, one.
Boom.
Now I broke the Guinness World Records.
So November 11th is known as
a Pocky (speaks in Japanese)
or Pocky Day in Japan.
This date was chosen because
a Pocky is shaped like a one.
At November 11th, visually,
it looks like four Pocky.
And also, Pretz are included
in this day, November 11th,
which is the pretzel version of Pocky.
And in Japan, you can get
them in flavors like Salad,
Ripe Tomato, Sweet Potato,
and Roasted Bread flavor.
In the US, we also have Pretz,
and we get these fun flavors
like Sweet Corn, fun,
and Pizza.
Oh, God.
It has nothing on it.
(Joe chomps)
Nope.
I mean, yeah, it tastes like corn.
Why though?
What is the demand for
corn-flavored sticks?
(Joe sighs)
Besides pizza, anything
flavored like pizza is terrible.
Even pizza combos aren't very good.
(Pretz wrapper crinkles)
No.
(Joe chomps)
I mean, it's up there with croutons.
Does anyone grab a handful
of croutons on-the-go?
And would just eating a box of croutons.
These probably would be good on something.
(catchy music)
- In Japan, our chocolate Pocky box,
per 100 grams, has 506 calories.
Adjusted for the box size, 72 grams,
the package contains 364.3 calories.
And let's break it down
even further to per Pocky.
One Pocky contains, on
average, 11.38 calories.
- A US chocolate Pocky
box contains 340 calories.
Just a little bit less
than a Japanese box,
but note, there is a two-gram difference.
Now here at "Food Wars", we
thrive on scientific accuracy.
So let's break it down per Pocky.
One US Pocky is 9.44444444444444444...
calories.
- The highest-calorie Pocky
in Japan is to be determined.
We emailed the customer service,
but we didn't get their response.
What are you doing? Hurry up!
But I guess this Pocky is
the most calorific Pocky.
It's 196 calories.
So it should be 'cause it's
got a lot of butter in it.
- The US Pocky
with the most calories
is the Cookies & Cream.
It contains total 630 calories.
There's no question I
can murder this whole box
in one sitting.
630 calories? That's nothing.
That's kind of reassuring
like, "Wow, only 630?
Found my breakfast!"
(steady music)
- Japa-Pocky contains these ingredients.
Wheat flour, sugar, cacao
mass, vegetable oils,
whole-milk powder,
shortening, malt extract,
starch, salt, yeast, cocoa powder, butter,
emulsifier, flavoring, leavening
agent, annatto coloring,
and mineral salt.
- Any US Pocky contains
wheat flour, sugar,
chocolate liquor, blend of vegetable oils,
that blend being sunflower oil, palm oil,
whole-milk powder,
vegetable oil shortening,
which is palm oil, hydrogenated
palm oil, and cocoa butter,
salt, artificial flavors,
yeast, soy lecithin,
leavening, sodium bicarbonate,
mono- and diglycerides of fatty acids.
Wink.
- In Japan, our Pocky
contains malt extract,
which is sometimes used as a replacement
for sugar in baking.
It contains lots of maltose,
a type of sugar
which actually has a
higher glycemic index value
than normal sucrose.
So it's a surprise that
American Pocky are supposed
to be sweeter.
- There are actually differences
in the types of cocoa used.
If you've watched the "US
versus UK Snickers" episode,
you know that American
chocolate is not so great.
In the US, our Pockys are
made with chocolate liquor
and cocoa butter.
Chocolate liquor is just
cocoa that's been processed
into semisolid form,
and it's actually around
50% cocoa butter itself.
The trouble is for an American product
to be classified as milk chocolate,
it only needs to contain
around 10% of chocolate liquor,
and the rest can be made up of sugars
and various ingredients.
- In Japan, the rules are different,
depending on the type of product.
Milk chocolate material must contain
at least 21% cocoa content,
double the required amount in America.
So our chocolate has more chocolate.
Are you jealous of us?
Come to Japan.
George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between 7-Eleven in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, our coffees come in regular --
Joe: In small, medium,
large,
George: And large.
and extra large.
If you're getting coffee,
why not grab a chocolate doughnut?
Our 7-Eleven drinks come in
sizes of 200 milliliters,
450 milliliters,
and 1 liter,
and 1.5 liters.
I'm sorry, I couldn't get it.
[laughing maniacally]
In the US, we have Big Gulps,
self-service fountain drink for sodas,
and they come in these four sizes:
medium, large, extra large,
double extra large.
[air horn rings]
So, I want to see how
much the biggest-size cup
I could get at the 7-Eleven is.
And to do that, I will need, hang on ...
It's just past 40.
It's exactly 48 ounces.
That's hardly double extra.
I'll round it up, 'cause
of this section here.
I'll round it up to 50.
7-Eleven also at one point offered a size
that was even bigger,
called the Team Gulp,
which, again, according to them,
was 128 fluid ounces
for your team,
'cause who doesn't like
to, after a softball game,
go to 7-Eleven, get a
Team Gulp and 10 straws?
You know, just kick it
with the boys, right?
Come on, team.
Yeah, right. That's for one
person, don't be ridiculous.
Here are many, many, many 7-Eleven items
you can get in the US
you can't get in Japan.
And here are many of the 7-Eleven items
exclusive to Japan.
Japan puts the "convenience"
in the convenience store.
We call it konbini,
which is the abbreviation
of the convenience store,
and it makes our life a lot easier.
For example, office workers
rely on stores like 7-Eleven
for food and drink to keep them happy
so that they can be productive at work.
And for students, they tend
to buy juices and snacks
and hot foods, instant noodles, you know.
And when I was a kid, I would often eat
hot foods and instant noodles
with my friends and
with my ex-girlfriends.
7-Eleven memories.
And for families, there is pretty much
every daily essential they may need.
And also you can pay your bills,
get ticket reservations
for music and sports,
7-Eleven even has its own bank and ATMs.
No matter where you go, especially
in big cities like Tokyo,
you can find more than one
konbini on every block.
Yeah, it's a bit different here in the US.
I do frequent 7-Eleven, and it's not bad,
but the vibe is more kind of like
get the thing you need and go.
The food is usually pretty hit or miss,
usually miss in my experience.
The hot food looks like it's
been sitting out for a while,
so I usually don't get it.
Since there are way too many
items exclusive to Japan
for us to buy for one episode,
so I've curated some of
my favorites for you guys.
This is still a ton of food.
So, here we have Japanese onigiris.
This one is plum,
tuna mayonnaise,
shrimp and mayonnaise,
mentaiko, which is spicy cod roe.
I picked these onigiris from the back,
because onigiri in the
back are fresh of all time.
And let me show you how to open this one.
Just pull this over till here ...
Like this, so that you can have
the dried seaweed.
Itadakimasu.
Mm, a little bit sweet,
a little bit of sour.
So, here is our sushi.
Look at this huge salmon sushi.
Ah!
Gorgeous. Gorgeous sushi.
Itadakimasu.
Oh, my God, this is so delicious.
Mm.
Osushi!
We've got this long natto roll.
Personally, I love natto.
But even Japanese people,
50% of them like it, 50%
of them don't like it.
This is an acquired taste.
So, after this sticky
and smelly natto roll,
I've got sushi roll special package.
So when it comes to this
one, it's called oinarisan.
It has rice inside,
and the skin is a sweet tofu skin.
Mm!
I'll admit, oinarisan umai wa.
This is so good.
So, my grandma always cooked this for me.
And this makes me happy all the time.
And next to oinarisan,
this gorgeous sushi roll,
it's like Japanese version
of California roll.
Itadakimasu.
Wah!
1,000% better than California roll.
Kanpyo maki.
In English it's, like, dried-gourd roll.
Itadakimasu.
Perfect sushi roll.
And last one, we have
pickles, radish pickles.
It's quite yellow.
It definitely has yellow No. 5.
Itadakimasu.
I'm gonna give them Grammy award.
And standing ovation.
Ah, the hot food at a 7-Eleven in the US.
We got a lot of options,
not as many as Japan.
I'm not quite sure what
some of this stuff is
just by looking at it, so
let me go down the list.
Nachos. They're the self-service nachos,
so they have the chips ready to go,
and then you just open them up
and add cheese and chili onto them.
Ugh. No, thank you.
Over here, these mini tacos.
Man, these look really, like ...
I bit my face.
Oh, man. They've been sitting for a while,
so I'll forgive them.
We also have wings,
crispy and not so crispy.
Pocket bean burrito guy. Look at that.
Over here in the roller-taquito section,
you can get a barbecue
bacon cheeseburger roller,
spicy garlic roller,
regular taquito,
Korean barbecue taquito.
Also, we have chicken sandwiches,
a black bean burger,
glazed cheesy barbecue meatballs.
Also at our 7-Elevens, you
can get a pepperoni pizza,
cheese, or seven-meat.
And also for hot dogs, we got
an exclusive hot picante dog.
No.
So, here are our hot food sections.
We've got steamed buns.
It's got pork and bamboo shoots.
And this is really standard nikuman.
So, next size up, we
have the doubled nikuman.
And next one, this little guy.
What is this?
Sweet beans steamed bun.
And last steamed bun is pizza bun.
You really are the pizza!
Delicious.
So, all these things, like,
around 100 yen to 200 yen or so.
So if you're broke, you
should definitely try this.
We've got these ones.
This one is called curry pan.
So deep-fried curry bread.
I wanna eat it. I wanna eat this!
I wanna eat this right now!
Itadakimasu!
Holy moly.
Um, it's freaking delicious.
And next one, croquette.
So it's basically got
potato and pork mince.
And last hot food we've got is corn dog.
So, this one right here is
a pretty Japanese-y one.
It's got ketchup and mustard,
and you just squeeze
this one onto this one.
All right, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go, let's go!
In Japan, we have these chicken options.
First, I'm going to start
with this one, karaage-bo.
So, in Japan, when you make
Japanese fried chicken,
you put some soy sauce on it.
So it has soy-sauce flavor
and also garlic flavor.
It's so freaking delicious.
So, this karaage-bo,
it's got one, two, three,
and four karaages.
We have fried chicken,
spicy fried chicken,
chicken nuggets.
Hot sandwich,
the Buffalo-style chicken slider.
The cheeseburger
and the bacon cheeseburger.
Look, I mean, can you
even tell which one's,
right, which one?
Huh?
I'm assuming, obviously,
this burger's been cooked.
More on this in the ingredients section.
7-Eleven in the US, and I think probably
here in Southern California,
has tacos and burritos.
Get yourself a chicken fajita taco,
al pastor taco.
Bet this one's good.
And a chorizo breakfast taco.
The spicy beef, bean, and cheese burrito.
This ain't any burrito, baby.
It's The Bomb.
Bombing out the toilet, good God.
You're getting this and
you're microwaving it there.
So if you're, like,
walking out the 7-Eleven
chomping on The Bomb,
like, better make it home in time.
'Cause oh, man, it's coming.
Empanadas, right?
Yuelei: Yeah.
I don't want this.
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in here
and then close the lid
like it's a coffin.
Go away forever.
All right, so here are my favorite bentos.
Let's take a look at this one.
It's called nori bento.
This one is a pretty popular one in Japan.
So it's got croquette,
a deep-fried fish cake,
fried fish with tartar sauce.
Kinpira gobo.
It's like Japanese traditional salad.
Pickles.
And as you can see right here,
it's got spicy cod roe.
Under this seaweed, it's
got rice and fish flakes.
I love this bento.
Like, when I was a student,
I think I would eat this every single day.
So, after my favorite one,
this one. Look at this!
So this one is a Korean-style beef bento.
Oh, man, smells so good.
Whoo!
Everything right here is so amazing.
Fantastic.
This is so mashisoyo.
Tonkatsu bento,
and it comes with this
sauce for this tonkatsu.
Look how thick it is.
So, outside from bentos,
we have soba, soba noodle.
Put this sauce first.
Put wasabi and dried seaweed.
And then you put water onto soba noodle.
It's getting moist.
And don't forget to put
green onions right here.
Itadakimasu.
So you put soba noodle in this box.
[slurping]
Umai!
I guarantee you can't stop eating this,
'cause it's so delicious.
Sorry I slurped the noodles.
Because Japanese people or Asian people
do make noises when you eat noodles.
We slurp.
Slurp!
Slurp right now!
They got the meals over there in Japan.
We got meals too,
like this ready-made ricotta-, Romano-,
and Parmesan-cheese-stuffed ravioli
topped with marinara sauce and mozzarella.
Ugh.
Just stop, stop doing this.
Stop, please.
Stop.
Oden.
So, oden is like Japanese
traditional hot pot.
It's got fish cake,
fried tofu, noodle thing.
This is made from potato.
Egg, radish.
In winter, when you eat this,
this warms you up, from your heart.
To your body.
And next, gratin doria.
So, obviously it's got meat
sauce and a lot of cheese.
Under this cheese, it's
got a lot of rice in there.
It's like Japanese Western food.
We have 7-Premium main dishes.
Naan and butter chicken curry.
And next we have 7-Premium side dishes.
Mackerel, grilled mackerel.
We also have mackerel in miso.
Saba miso is [chef's kiss].
Smoked tongue.
In Japan, it's a pretty popular item,
especially when you go to a
Japanese barbecue restaurant,
we order the beef tongue or pig tongue.
So this one used to be like this.
Smells so good.
So fancy.
It's marvelous.
So, after this sexy tongue,
we have sexy fish cake.
And look at this bar.
It's a chicken bar,
so it's like a chicken
nugget before it's fried.
Octopus and wasabi.
This is just raw octopus.
Kinpira gobo. It's sautéed burdock.
Hijikini, stewed hijiki seaweed.
And potato salad.
So, when I go home, my mom always cooks
this one, this one, this one.
I love you, Mom.
I miss Mom's cooking.
And next we have Premium Gold main dishes.
Shrimp with chili sauce.
Beef stew.
Hamburg steak.
Sandwiches, 7-Eleven.
Egg salad.
Peanut butter and jelly.
Turkey and cheddar
cheese on a kaiser roll.
So, we have the Italian-style sub,
but then we also got The Italian Job.
Turkey and ham with, is that
cheese in the picture there?
We got the smoked turkey and
Monterey Jack cheese sandwich,
and they separated the lettuce,
so you add it right before
you're ready to eat,
so it's still nice and crisp.
Salads, chicken Caesar salad.
We also have a pepperoni pasta salad.
So, here are my favorite sandwiches.
It's got tuna right here
and cheese and lettuce.
And the rest of these are ham and egg.
I thought this is normal,
but you don't have this one,
fruit sandwich.
So it's got a whole bunch of fruits.
It's got peach, pineapples,
and oranges on whipped cream.
So it's like cake.
So, here is 7-Premium drip coffee.
So I'm going to make
myself a cup of coffee.
Heyo!
And he just sits on here.
Ah! Ah ah ah!
Ah!
Mm.
All right.
Itadakimasu.
It tastes like shit.
So, for breakfast sandwiches at 7-Eleven,
you can get yourself a croissant
with ham, egg, and cheese.
Ooh, an English muffin with
bacon, egg, and cheese.
We also have English muffins
with sausage, egg, and cheese,
sausage biscuits,
and sausage, egg, and cheese croissants.
The 7-Eleven signature brand also has
mini doughnuts, chocolate,
cinnamon, crunch,
and, of course, powdered.
Madeleines.
7-Eleven has cookies right
at the register for a dollar.
You can get yourself some
macadamia nut cookies,
oatmeal raisin, sugar,
but there's also a
chocolate chip cookie one.
Baked goods, you get
yourself some muffins.
This is a blueberry muffin.
Coffee cake.
Crispy rice treat bar.
Notice it doesn't say Rice Krispie,
'cause you know that's copywritten.
Walnut fudge brownie,
bear claw Danish,
iced honey bun,
cheese Danish,
mixed berry Danish,
glazed honey bun.
I got these prepackaged, it
says "flavored snack pie."
That's a weird way of putting it.
Lemon, key lime, banana cream.
I feel like they used the
same -- that's the same.
That's Photoshop right there, buddy.
Boston cream, apple,
and the last one, strawberry cheesecake.
Key lime.
Look at all that cream in there.
It's key limey.
Oh, yeah.
Oatmeal!
That's obviously maple syrup right there.
But the first thing I
did when I looked at it,
I was like, "Wait, does
this have brandy in it?"
Boozy oatmeal.
You can put hot water in here, Joe.
Or hot milk, Yuelei.
Or hot whiskey.
Your boss won't notice the difference.
Well, at first.
Here we have Japanese type of bread.
Stir-fried-noodles-and-sauce bread.
We call it yakisoba pan.
Now, you may be thinking what
the [dolphin chirps] is this?
So, it's like hot dog,
but instead of sausage,
we've got stir-fried noodle inside.
Carb, carb.
It makes you fat.
Bread makes you fat?!
So, kids love this noodle and bread.
Itadakimasu.
Mm!
This one reminds me of my childhood,
me playing tags in the
mountain and chasing the girls.
Now a lot of girls chasing me.
This is a crab bread.
It's got two crab-shaped bread.
Now, the question is,
does it taste like crab?
It doesn't taste like crab.
Taste like just bread.
Pink bread.
It's a
cherry-blossom-flavored-coating bread.
This pink stuff is,
it's pretty sour.
It tastes like cherry blossom
and like my first kiss.
This is the salty, savory snack zone.
Ah, so much stuff.
And I've hit the "Food Wars" wall.
Hot and spicy cracklin
curls, the original,
and the fried pork rinds, chili lime.
I'm not tasting anything
pork-related to it.
Little pig guy there.
Little piggy guy.
You're on the menu, buddy.
Next, 7-Selects has
their own veggie straws.
This will be the trail
mix and mix-like section.
We got these
cheese-pizza-flavored snack mix.
You're gonna be a stinky boy
if you have a bunch of these.
Now they got the spicy ranch flavor mix.
And this last one, just sesame sticks.
For those of you who like
to get your trail mix
or your Chex Mix and then unmix them
and organize them and eat them like that,
7-Eleven has got the snack for you.
Oh, this is kind of a party snack mix.
Eh.
This is what I would totally
get, yogurt pretzels.
They put yogurt on there,
and, like, you're thinking,
"Oh, yogurt, that's healthy, right?"
I mean, it's just, it's the same as icing.
Now, you're looking at this going,
"Jack Link's beef jerky?
That's not a 7-Eleven brand."
No, it's not.
But as you can see,
exclusive 7-Eleven flavors.
See, this was like, "Hey,
Jack Link's, guess what?
We're about to push you
out of our shelf space.
So do a deal with us, or
you're gone completely."
And Jack Link's was like,
"No, I've got kids to feed, please!"
Brown sugar bourbon,
original recipe,
original.
Hickory-smoked bacon.
Like snacking on cheese and nothing else?
Full house, baby.
This one is mozzarella cheese
wrapped in hard salami.
Pepper Jack stick,
Gouda cheese to go.
Oh, the big one, the big
cheese, the white cheddar.
This ain't your grandma's cheese.
It's the big one.
Just two.
Cheddar cheese.
Colby-Jack, which is
like camouflage cheese.
Ugh!
Pretzels. Mini twists, non yogurted.
Pretzel nuggets. Ooh, gross.
These ones have peanut
butter inside of them.
Pretzel sticks. I feel like
there was a while there
in the early '90s when they were like,
"Chips are bad for you.
Eat pretzels instead."
And these are really salty, too.
A serving size of these is three.
I would get this assuming I'm gonna sit
and eat this whole bag in one sitting.
I'm not gonna do three at a time.
The whole bag is 1,160 milligrams,
50% of your sodium intake.
Mini rice cakes.
Chips.
7-Eleven has a bunch of
their own potato chips,
including the original, fiery hot.
Kettle chips, which are way better
than regular chips, again.
Spicy jalapeño, smoked Gouda.
Ooh, Gouda.
Barbecue, salt and pepper.
Ruffles rip-offs. We got
cheddar and sour cream.
Prime rib, I'm trying these.
And Buffalo chicken dip.
Prime rib?
Woof, smells terrible.
Oh, my God, that was so bad!
It's definitely not this.
Yeah, more like ground beef.
And instead of one of these fancy forks,
there'd be the plastic spork
that they have at 7-Eleven.
They're opening the bag with the spork,
meat's pouring out of it,
it's on the floor of a 7-Eleven,
with a guy mopping around it.
Nuts, baby. Nuts.
The rise and shine fiber blend
of a trail mix, whatever.
Antioxidant. Yeah, right.
Revive and thrive,
another antioxidant mix.
Should've just handed
these out during COVID,
would've bounced back in a week.
Cashew halves.
You like your nuts halved? Booyah.
You like your nuts wholed? Booyah.
Does it matter if they're whole or not?
Would that affect the
flavor at all? Who cares?
Spicy ranch pistachios.
And, of course, jumbo flavored
wasabi and soy nuts. Nope.
Wasabi will never touch my
lips again after that video.
So, here are my favorite instant noodles.
Let's start.
Ippudo ramen.
Man, I love this.
So, it's got some packets.
Dried pork.
It's a miso for the ramen soup.
Dried veggies.
And it's got noodles.
All right.
And you've got to wait for three minutes.
So while I'm waiting for
this, I'm gonna go this one.
So it's called Ippei-chan.
So it basically is a yakisoba.
Yakisoba is like Japanese
stir-fried noodles.
So, you put some hot
water until this line.
All right, so it's been three minutes.
Put this soup into this bowl.
Mix it.
Smells so good!
Bravo.
So, Ippudo has a lot
of locations in Japan,
including Tokyo, but this taste,
this flavor is totally the same
as the restaurant's serving.
So just get it at 7-Eleven.
Oh, shit, I totally forgot the, oh.
So, I put some hot water, but --
oh, shit!
I should have thrown the
water away into the toilet.
Gomen ne, noodles.
Let's make yakisoba.
[laughs] The volume of these noodles
gets a lot bigger.
OK, so put yakisoba sauce.
And flakes.
And most importantly, mayo.
Mayo beam!
Oh!
And mix it up.
Ta-da!
So, this is yakisoba.
We usually eat this,
like, at summer festival.
Pretty good, as always.
Next, we have tako-meshi.
Look at this. So, it's got green onions,
and I believe this is tako.
So, three minutes again.
Look at this final noodle.
It says ultra-spicy final.
You're going to be crying
because of the spiciness.
It's too spicy.
But I'm going to try this,
only for shooting purpose.
This is for you guys!
We can do it.
Clip: Never give up!
Oh, man, I'm so scared.
All right, so I think
it's time to eat this one.
So, I'm going to throw the
water away in the toilet again.
Let's go to the toilet.
And put yakisoba sauce.
All righty.
And the taste itself is
lighter than this one.
I prefer this one, but,
but,
this is the king ramen.
All right, so finally let's make
the freaking spicy noodle.
I call it death sauce.
In case I'm dead,
please find another Japanese host.
It was nice to meet you, Food Insider.
Go!
Oh, man, look at this.
It's not red, it's blood.
I don't want to eat this.
[coughing]
Ah!
Oh.
I'm not joking, I'm not joking.
Ah, ah.
It hurts!
Am I alive?
Am I not dead?
Am I in heaven?
Hell?
I feel like I'm in hell.
It's not all junk food at
the 7-Eleven, Joe and Yuelei.
They also have delicious
freshly sliced fruit.
Prepackaged and everything,
came straight from the ground,
and it comes in a
container that will be here
until the sun explodes.
This, I mean, this has to be an LA thing.
You can get mango with
tajin seasoning.
Automated voice: Tajin.
Fantastic combination.
Finally, grape cup.
7-Eleven also has its own
brand of packaged candies.
Sour gummy bears,
sour neon gummy worms,
sour watermelon wedges,
green apple rings,
gummy worms for catching gummy fish.
Heh-heh. You like that?
Fruit leather, whatever we call this.
Chili mango. Hell yeah, I'm trying these.
Sweetened mango,
and a sweetened fruit medley.
Not bad. Oh, a little
spicier that I thought, whoa.
There's also gummy bears and gummy sharks.
There's also gummy peach rings.
They got jelly beans,
and they got sour cherries.
7-Eleven Selects in the US also has
their own line of sandwich cookies.
Vanilla, pumpkin spice,
double chocolate, peppermint,
s'mores, the duplexes,
lemon crème.
Mm-mm-mm.
So, here are Japanese sweets.
Pink rice cake with red bean paste.
So basically it's like
cherry blossom mochi.
Itadakimasu.
Mm, mm.
I want to eat this under
the tree of cherry blossom.
Cherry blossom, pew.
Next, we have ninja gummy.
He's like ninja salaryman.
So, it's a hard gummy.
It's really tough, like stones.
[crunching]
Toppo.
It's like Pocky, but
the chocolate is inside.
I'm loving it.
Look at this cute guy!
Koala no Machi.
Koala's March Chocolate.
My favorite would be this one.
When I was a kid, I would
eat this every single day.
And this taste is so nostalgic.
Oh, little George is calling me like,
"Hey, I wanna eat this! I wanna eat -- "
Hey! We are filming right now.
Later, after shooting, OK?
"OK."
OK. We're good.
Pudding.
Please prepare the plate.
And you just do like this.
One, two, three, go.
The shape is like cherry blossom.
Look how jelly it is.
Mm!
This is the best pudding ever.
We had to go on a run to get more stuff.
That's why visually this
all doesn't connect.
7-Eleven's got macarons, French macarons.
Ooh, mini cheesecakes,
New York style and strawberry swirl.
These I can get behind.
Our 7-Eleven in the US has ice cream,
such as banana cream pie,
caramel butter pecan,
chocolate-covered strawberry,
double cookie dough,
cookies 'n' cream, sea-salt caramel,
strawberry-banana shortcake.
So, let's start with cold stuff.
We've got fried dumplings. It's frozen.
Frozen takoyaki,
frozen fried rice.
So, after these frozen
meals, I got ice cream.
Choco Monaka Jumbo.
So, Choco Monaka Jumbo
is like Japanese ice cream sandwich.
Ah!
Let me bite. Itadakimasu.
Sorry, it looks gross. [laughs]
So it's got ice cream,
and it's got chocolate in the middle,
and this crunchy on the outside.
Every Japanese people get this one
at least once in their life.
And last ice cream, I got this one.
Gorilla chocolate ice cream. [laughs]
I don't know what this is.
Ah.
Ah! Ch-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t!
Ah, sorry! Itadakimasu!
This is delicious.
Not only me, but Gorilla would love this.
Lot of exclusive drinks.
I don't know really where to begin,
so I kind of lined them up
by perception of healthiness.
So, all the way down
on this end, we've got
7-Eleven Select Go Smart
cold organic pressed juices.
This one's the tropical glow.
And this gross-looking one is, of course,
clean and green.
After that, we got these
prepackaged juices.
These are the 7-Select Farmer's Grove.
Cranberry cocktail, raspberry lemonade,
orange juice, of course, regular lemonade.
Then next up in the bigger ones
we have the 7-Eleven teas.
Peach black tea, sweet tea.
They weren't kidding, man, look at that.
Lemon sweet tea
and green tea.
Fruit punch, mango, guava.
Energy, come on, herbal tonic.
Herbal? This is herbal, guys? Yeah?
7-Eleven also their own brand of ...
are these considered energy drinks?
The Gatorades and Powerades and the like.
So Replenish, and of
course Replenish zero.
I'm assuming zero added sugar.
Orange mango, fruit punch, lemonade.
The cherry is clear.
What? Why is cherry clear?
Guava splash, orange mango.
♪ These are bad ♪
7-Eleven energy.
"Strawberry lemonade energy shot,
one and half times the
caffeine of a cup of coffee."
Oh, good God.
Undrinkable.
How bad does it have to
taste where this is too --
I couldn't get to this?
You've seen this show, right?
You'll see what I'll tolerate.
This, I can barely tolerate this.
Here's something that
they don't have in Japan.
They don't have Slurpees.
That's nuts, right?
Slurpees are -- how do
you describe a Slurpee?
It's like a flavored slush.
We have endless Slurpee flavors.
The ones currently you can
get here in America are
blue rocketberry,
blood orange,
Vitaminwater XXX,
blue raspberry,
blueberry lemonade bliss,
cherry, Coca-Cola,
Mountain Dew citrus, peach perfect,
piña colada, and pineapple whip.
So, here are Japanese exclusive drinks.
We have vegetable juice, of course.
Mm! Oishii.
A lot of Japanese salarymen
drink this one every morning
to get their day started.
So this one is for Joe.
Joe, you're missing a lot of veggies,
so you should drink this one.
Oi Ocha, my favorite green tea.
And these two are hot drinks,
black coffee and café latte.
And this is our first time filming this.
We have alcohol.
We have 7-Premium beer.
And this one is not beer.
It's like Sprite with alcohol.
It contains 9% of alcohol.
It's pretty delicious,
but at the same time,
it's pretty dangerous.
Japanese sake.
When you come to Japan, you can see
a lot of people drinking alcohol outside.
They're like [groans].
They are not dead, they're just sleeping.
They're drunk.
Whisky.
7-Eleven in the US has its own
private brand wines,
Yosemite Road, Trojan Horse,
Plot and Point, and Voyager Point.
It also has its own canned
wine brand, called Roamer.
Perhaps the reason 7-Eleven
has such a wide variety
of products in Japan is that
it's everywhere in Japan.
There are 21,215 stores in Japan.
That's crazy!
Which is nearly 30% of all
the 7-Elevens in the world.
Of course, all 37
prefectures have a 7-Eleven.
And out of all of them,
the city of Tokyo has the most locations,
with 2,850.
To put that in perspective,
the US has 9,417 7-Elevens,
and there's no 7-Elevens in 18 states.
As far as states, California has the most,
1,823.
But as far as denseness in area,
Las Vegas, Nevada, has the most, with 158.
In Japan, our hot dog is 290 calories
and 720 milligrams of sodium,
which is 31.3% of your daily allowance.
Our hot dog is 180 calories.
Ooh. How about this?
Our hot dog is 180 calories,
but for the frank only.
The stats, for some reason,
don't say anything about the bun.
But this isn't much better for you.
It's 570 milligrams of sodium,
so around 24.8% of your daily allowance.
Japan's hand-rolled tuna and mayo onigiri
has 258 calories and is very filling.
Remember this guy? The tuna sandwich.
Here in the US, ours is 420 calories
and lots of sodium, over 800 milligrams.
Fuck!
And in the US, a Super
Big Gulp of Coca-Cola,
this isn't Coca-Cola, is 44 fluid ounces.
It's 513 calories and 143 grams of carbs.
That's over half your daily intake.
In Japan, 7-Eleven does not disclose
the ingredients list of its
freshly made food items.
It does, however, tell
us the country of origin
for the raw materials for certain items,
like the fried food, yakitori, oden,
and Chinese steamed buns.
The chicken for our fried
chicken is from Thailand.
The pork for our sausages and hot dogs
comes from USA, Canada, and Japan.
The wheat for the buns comes from Canada,
the USA, and Japan.
And adzuki beans come from Canada,
cheese comes from New Zealand,
and the shrimp for the shrimp
chili buns is from Vietnam.
This is the pepperoni pizza in the US.
And it contains all this junk.
I mean, what's this thing?
Never heard of that.
What about chicken strips?
It's got all this stuff!
Just like mom used to make.
And, of course, the 7-Eleven
Select cheeseburger,
which contains ... [sighs]
sesame seed bun has enriched flour,
excuse me, enriched wheat flour,
wheat flour, niacin, reduced iron,
monoserititate, serotitititate,
calcium propionate as a
preservative, calcium sulfate,
royal beef patty got smoke flavor added,
and it's beef, encapsulated
salt, potassium ...
Is anything else after that?
Salt, spice, pasteurized
process American cheese.
Ah, cheese -- they're sitting down.
That's how long this is going.
My cameraperson just sat down.
A preservative, paprika,
and annatto color.
So I guess the last takeaway
from this video is that in the US,
some of our 7-Eleven items can be
a little bit of a gamble with your health.
Speaking of gambling, you know your boy
got some scratchers when
he was over at 7-Eleven.
Mm-hmm, OK. So there's
the winning numbers.
OK, so we didn't win anything on that one.
I have no clue how to do this.
Did I win?
If you haven't subscribed
yet, subscribe now!
'Cause we were filming this for six hours.